[Applause]
Mr Mayor I hope you will
understand if I have to ask you
at this time of remembrance to commemorate
my father's belief together with me therese stadt
perished
do you mean the auschwitz camp
perished my mother who was in the same camp in
the  died
in the gas chamber and my first wife who had to
give up her young life in the bergen
belsen camp i ask you
not to expect even a single
word of
hate from me who should i hate i
only knew the victims but i know them  not the
perpetrators at least i don't know the
perpetrators personally and someone not
personally but collectively
guilty teaching is correct
there is no collective guilt and
believe me i'm not just saying that
today i said it from the first
day i left a
last concentration camp
was liberated and i believe that the men and
women in austria today  are between
59 years old collectively guilty
is a crime and is
insanity and don't let it be phrased as yes
it would be a crime if it weren't a
case of
insanity plus a tumble like the
nazi ideology that
seven liability
the show says thelen who believe they can say
that today you
didn't do anything yourself for bus or even just any thing, you did
n't even refrain from doing it yourself,
but the parents or grandparents have to
take their conscience
and i think i see myself to be sure
of that  the victims of former collective
persecution should be the first and
be the ones who would agree with me
if it were because they
were designed to drive the youth of today to hug the
old man under the neo-
nazis many can
come back to liberation for the moment
i am in the first possible transport,
even if only illegally possible transfer
to vienna s  he started driving along
with a few other viennese people including la
rosa jochmann in a truck
on august 15, 1945
since then i have been called to america 63 times
by universities and so on
and so on
and each time of these 63 times i have
returned to austria not because
i would have loved the austrians so much
but because
love is based in austria he doesn't always want to know
mutual advice don't you
have americans mr franke why
didn't you actually come to us before the war
and my answer was that
i knew explain to them  for years i had
to guess an entry visa to america
and when it finally
happened it was already too
late
because i just couldn't bring
myself to leave my parents alone in the middle of the war with the old
parents and face
their fate under the
national socialists
but rather that I chose
to share this fate and then
the americans say that's all well and good but
why weren't you really rich after
the war came to us in america
why did you return to vienna
that many did too less to
you and yours then i say to the
americans
look in vienna there is a to
given an example by a catholic baroness
,
the discoverer and promoter of
the monastery work I noticed that
alfons petzold and she kept a cousin
of mine
well hidden
in her apartment throughout the war as having saved her life
and giving another example against you
there was a socialist
lawyer in vienna
who always put
himself at risk slipped me a liter of
life you know who that was it
was bruno pittermann and then i ask
the americans now they tell me
why i had to go to a city where their faces
not to
keep coming back
I know full well
I know full well what you're going to have up now
or what you hold against us
he asks you let's be honest
these were big exceptions
exceptions to the rule and usually
bad orb replaced resistance you should
have put up and i have to agree with you
more down there but please
consider that resistance  even once
before heroism and erich must you can in
my view actually be allowed to
ask a single
person
that's you and those who say you should
rather let yourself be locked up before
you make compromises
that's how the nazis were hired and
so on
absolutely correct  but actually
only someone who
has given proof of his life can say that
he preferred to be placed in a
concentration camp instead of somehow
getting rid of himself and his convictions
[applause]
we all have votes, you can
understand them today  young generation how are they supposed to
understand that like
the people used to, e.g  they had to worry about
their freedom and their lives about the
fate of their families for which they were
responsible
all of this you have to think about but all the
more must the miracles the people in
the boat had at risk of their lives to
join the many starts movement
and even having to
go to regular schools for that, just like my
best friend, his name
robert,
was sentenced to death by the wehrmacht and his young deer
ended up under the guillotine, ladies
and gentlemen, national socialism brought
up the racial madness, but if
I may reveal it  how i think about
it my answer is that there are
actually only two human races that
is the race of decent people
and the races of decent people and
racial segregation dietrich still hasn't made a
commitment
[applause]
many people keep a few small
groups with others who are in the
concentration camps  one here and there
even under it's on  encountered one or the
other halfway decent terror
as well as vice versa so
many lured among the prisoners of
the vaart threatens only all
decent people are in the
minority the employment people were
in my minorities will i think
if i stay mine but the danger
is there  the st the danger lies where
a political system the
naughty guys pan the surface and in
other words make it so much more
negative selection comes across nation from
that's actually driven here
[
applause] not a single nation and in
that sense i was the assertion  that
basically every nation is capable of
brokaw and what are the political
consequences that we are allowed to have on all of the goals in
my opinion there are only two games
of politics or let me tell you
two busts of politicians like one these
are the ones who believe the end
justifies the means
every weakness
terrorist will be included  n the other
politicians are very well set to
stay in their jobs that there are ways that they themselves
would like to escape the filings path to shed
light on this type of politician
i also want to trust that he will learn from everything
these march days locally di
milano and hear the demand of the
day or better said this
commemoration day and that can only be that
all the boys finally want to stretch out their hands
green everywhere
[applause]
after this deeply touching and
important speech by
broadsoft frankfurt the big rally comes to an end